[Music]
in when trampolines attack news bouncy
bouncy bounce emitted by hello from the
UK hi Oh a young boy was impaled by a
trampoline spring that came loose and
shot into his back oh my dad [ __ ] dude
Ripley did you [ __ ] you up like I got
mess up it could you like bouncy
confident a couple backflips your foot
ends up I never got spring stuffed but
like my foot ended up through the spring
kind of hurt yeah I know my mom used to
make me jump on a trampoline I along
it's good for circulation well like you
mean a small one yeah the small early
with small big fine like $20 one cuz I
had asthma so my mom want me to work it
out so like while my mom was getting
ready for work she's like I want that
she looks out the window and if I'm not
like jumping she'll look down make sure
like hold the stick we're gonna [ __ ]
beat you what if you're meant to be a
frail little kid but because your mom
whipped you like into North Korean style
you were able to get into like and
[ __ ] overcome your weakness you know
she let me do that and this should make
me do like jump rope in stuff I think
that's how I actually got good at jump
rope was just because I've started at a
young age and it should make you go back
on the track how does she know that in
order for you to cuz they I would be
afraid to trigger your asthma attacks a
Chinese remedy I like it I like it
she starts playing on I have the tiger
anything else if he gets a little bit
sick you can sweat it out Filipino dude
what's the heater up way up and then he
puts on sweats and like a bunch of
layers of clothes I'm surprised your mom
didn't give you a pack of cigarettes
like here for your asthma smoking away
smoke your way into the [ __ ] open
lungs
alright y'all this is of course a freak
accident that happens all the time 12
year old kid jumping on the trampoline I
think he was by himself when this
happened
he's jumping on the trampoline and it
happened very abruptly
one of the springs snapped off and it
shot out and they're estimating it to be
a seventy miles per hour
Oh
Springs do you ever have a big
trampoline I have a big one but I had
the small one and then I remember I
visited my mom when I got a little bit
older she still had it I did jump on it
and I was too heavy already and in the
hit the thing and it touched the floor
yeah but you can see the spring is like
stretching we had a big one and those
things are probably like like a little
small on a water bottle but they're
pretty boy you about to see it yeah I
mean is it one of those big ones in the
backyard I don't care I blew it up did
you guys know that there are I think
they said ninety seven ninety four
thousand emergency room treated
trampoline - it's dangerous you know
they're super dangerous they are so you
get a look carpet I'm tell you you look
confident
you think you watch the Olympics one
year and you're [ __ ] what did you do I
was doing a bunch of back flips and I
was like pretty good you know and so I
do like a backflip that was like ol back
for the 180 and I chart like a backflip
360 or whatever and you just land like
like the sandwich on your neck though
and then you wake up you get the air
knocked out of you and you're and you're
like 12 and you're like did I just
you've never felt pain like I think we
were talking earlier like some kids you
just don't really feel pain or like real
pain and then you're so seven the wind
knocked out of me once and I'll let your
[ __ ] yeah you get that plus a neck
ache and you're like oh my god I never
went all that [ __ ] hard disk or some
shoe I'll probably kill myself I think
usually killers I used to do so many
flips into my mom said that you could
you be paralyzed if you land wrong and
then I was too scared to do any flips
over oh you're such a good kid my mom
would threaten me with paralysis about
everything like don't do that face get
paralyzed don't do that you might break
your spine and then be paralyzed for
life don't do that I might be in a
wheelchair forever at all falling into
place
yeah I do it does it make sense this is
all me yeah that's how I know that you
were as religious as I because every
time my mom tried to pull that [ __ ] I
got I got Jesus
[Laughter]
so so this so he's jumping on the
trampoline
this [ __ ] shoots out at 70 miles
per hour and it embeds six inches back
that's a bullet barely that's right a
lot of kidneys it's fine my god
look how big that thing is I put mine
together I was old enough to put
together with my dad that's bad yeah
yeah those things are like a football
it didn't puncture an organ no I just
about six inches aren't no your weight
thicker [ __ ] but a kid might be six
inches oh yeah you can't pull that out
yeah whoops are huge no I know I I just
want you to feel this I saw bowties
okay you guys people did you keep it for
my therapy hey that didn't puncture in
love I don't mean it it sounds like you
just had to have surgery to remove it um
it miss it misses spine ah but I don't
want tram please don't have a little
bouncy house where you go in the whole
building
does got to be a lawsuit waiting to
happen yeah I heard like one of them
like I think it crashed down on the kids
and then like they all were stuck in
there and like people were suffocating
yeah movies maybe even the movies are
dangerous nowadays we had the neighbor
remember we did a story the neighbor
unplugged the bouncy house oh yeah he
was sick of the noise or whatever like
all the kids that were getting smothered
and you're like a best case best best
case you're breaking your leg that's the
best case if your kid and your parents
give you this thing best case you're
breaking your leg you seen those YouTube
videos and legs going this way in a way
so you don't recommend having work I
don't think I look I'm no doctor and I'm
no parent discount just have him have a
friend who has one and he'll
occasionally visit I think that's even
worse because then you're not good at it
yeah you're just showing up get all
risky cuz little Timmy's doing triple
back flips and then Tigers trying to do
one thank you like anybody I know that
could do like a [ __ ] dribble dribble
on trampoline like you can't do it
standing what's the [ __ ] point what
talent do you have now you
stand-up towel is but it was fun out
because it's fun another fun [ __ ] you
could do this much no we'd some dumb
[ __ ] we do some dumb [ __ ] that [ __ ]
before we got a pool we would get a hose
you ever jump off the trampoline to the
pine through the pool is only 5 feet
right you did have a fun childhood a
great job the one I wanted like I look
at it and I'd be like I want that one
trampoline and you put the hose you know
the old school sprinklers before you
could have a sprinkler set you put that
underneath it yeah you're sliding around
and you're [ __ ] breakdancing so fun
yeah I'm lucky all I had was a making
the pool the trampoline I did have a
bother
ok y'all because out of mom and a dad -
dad - get the trampoline into the pool
after I told him but the pool is only
like 5 feet still good enough don't do
it kids
I'm Ike I invite to my friends over -
I'm tired everybody bring your bathing
suits and she does hose we did that you
know we did that - I did all that to
take and you're playing like a limbo
with it no my mom they got that yeah she
was inside she doesn't [ __ ] the
sprinklers are fun - yeah I did it all I
couldn't swim cuz that was just enough
that like I could get like you know I
could have a little moisture on me and
feel like one of those white kids is
good enough you know you can't swim
stare no why would I need to learn to
swim no eating on a boat I want me to
[ __ ] wait wait wait wait plane crash
what about earthquake that's my time
then I dunno you don't know you don't
want a snorkel you don't want to sweep
with a turtle my wonderful underwater
I'm trying to put me in swimming classes
but I didn't want to do it because I had
to wear a cap and no one else had to
wear a cap what do you have to work out
cuz I'm black in my ear can't get wet
who cares
learn how to swim there were started
kids with their hairs all in the water
and then I was I look like a damn egg I
also understand not wanting to swim or
snorkel because I don't do any of that
you can they can attest to that but I do
know how to swim and like if sue Nami
comes from Santa Monica I'm gonna live
but here's a thing can't you be your
hair wet even now Nicki asking like like
first more questions do it even now I'm
not gonna get my friends I swim without
our seat well the good I don't know
what's going on there even when we went
to the damn sauna I put one of that I
did I not put that hat on I sure did
this is something that you have been
telling yourself and it's been your what
the worst thing that happened the work
is currently I have to waste two hours
of my time doing it as a five my mom
don't have time for that but yeah but I
think you should learn how to swim
no I think so I get my hair wet my butt
now you can wear a cap you got
confidence that's true I would I would
put the cap right now I'd put the swim
cap one now what is it for anyways for
speed you have to wear that cap no
matter what hair yeah out into the water
dirty ass hair because your skin's not
good so you would have hated watching
Asians like tourists come to Santa
Monica beach like clothes like France or
some yeah they like wear t-shirts all
everyone for everyone they just want to
be naked
I don't wanna be naked I know I get that
I've been getting real dark lately I'll
be in real dark it came out of nowhere I
don't know what happened when I was like
in the basement gaming forever I look
like him well Whitman I don't think I
look like Mike no do I've been chatting
this summer that's not that bad
you're not that far off look I got tan
that's it I'm around full circle
I still remember being in school at like
in elementary school and white kids
would be like oh look that's not that
bad but I just did it to him
it's come around full because that's
that's pretty good it they would
literally I'm almost darker than you I
think I've has no one ever had that
happen to me all the time
yeah you just shake yeah my white side
of my family does that to me yeah yeah
really
hmm I used to be really creamy mochi
yeah and I got brown yeah you toast it
yeah I went to Hawaii Oh Turtles cuz I
know how to swim okay we just right this
is racism know how to swim it is fitting
some stereotypes making up excuses why
you don't want to learn to swim I'll buy
you a car that is a boy okay is that
dude I just want you to come to Hawaii
with us so you could feel the joy of
swimming what a turtle if I change I'm
fun it's one of the best joys in this
world to swim with a boy because the
Sharks
there's no shark are you shots don't
like warm water really cold water that's
why they're moving north talk about
global warming go to Hawaii all the time
I have what I call water ignorant cute I
don't you scared of what you don't know
what that's the definition of believe
that's the definition of fear things we
don't understand were scared of ya so
bugging me what do you mean you
shouldn't be scared and [ __ ] you don't
know what could be scared of things you
understand
oh if they're bad yeah Fabia's are when
you don't understand it I'm afraid of
killers
[Music]
you
[Music]